Good evening.
Those may are making dinner.
What are we making, Charlie?
Uh, I don't know.
No? Yeah. I didn't tell you.
Chicken lentil soup.
The Charles chopped all these vegetables,
put them in.
He's my helper.
I'm doing dishes and telling him what to do.
He's doing it for me.
I'm gonna show you.
So we have on the website our new French salts,
black pepper and French salt blend,
which is the most amazing blend ever.
I use it for everything, literally.
So this soup calls for salt and pepper,
and we just ran out.
I put them in my little canisters,
so I'm opening another bag.
Hello? I'm trying to.
Daddy! Daddy! Pig!
Ah, there.
I love this salt and pepper blend.